- You've said that the
meaning of life is to win.
If you look five years into the future,
what does winning look like?
- So...
There's a lot of,
I can go into like technical depth
to what I mean by that, to win.
It may not mean,
I was criticized for that in the comments,
like doesn't this guy
want to save the penguins
in Antarctica or like?
Look man, listen to what I'm saying.
I'm not talking about I
have a yacht or something.
I am an agent.
I am put into this world and
I don't really know what my purpose is.
But if you're an intelligent agent
and you're put into a world,
what is the ideal thing to do?
Well, the ideal thing mathematically,
you can go back to Schmidt
Hoover theories about this
is to build a compressive
model of the world,
to build a maximally compressive,
to explore the world
such that your exploration function
maximizes the derivative
of compression of the past.
Schmidt Hoover has a paper about this.
And like I took that kind of
as like a personal goal function.
So when I mean to win,
I mean like,
maybe this is religious
but like I think that in the future
I might be given a real purpose
or I may decide this purpose myself
and then at that point,
now I know what the game is
and I know how to win.
I think right now
I'm still just trying to
figure out what the game is
but once I know.
- So you have imperfect information,
you have a lot of uncertainty
about the reward function
and you're discovering it
but the purpose is--
- [George] That's a better way to put it.
- The purpose is to maximize it
while you have a lot of
uncertainty around it.
And you're both reducing that certainty
and maximizing it at the same time.
So that's at the technical level.
- If you believe in the universal prior,
what is the universal reward function?
That's the better way to put it.
- So that win is interesting.
I think I speak for
everyone in saying that
I wonder what that reward
function is for you
and I look forward to seeing that
in five years, in 10 years.
I think a lot of people, including myself,
are cheering you on man.
So I'm happy you exist
and I wish you the best of luck.